un décor de carte postale et les ténors
du gouvernement trudeau pour accueillir
le chancelier allemand le canada déroule
le tapis rouge est réellement une
opportunité pour le canada et
l'allemagne d'approfondir l'amitié
visite officielle sur fond de crise
énergétique en allemagne alors que la
russie ferme partiellement le robinet du
gaz justin trudeau se présente en allier
les deux leaders se prépare à signer un
accord d'exportation d'hydrogène vert
destiné à l'allemagne canada et fait des
victimes
le canada va jouer un rôle important
dans le développement des énergies
renouvelables dit le chancelier allemand
justin trudeau promet aussi d'être au
rendez-vous pour livrer du gaz naturel à
l'allemagne ils évoquent avec prudence
la possible renaissance de projets de
terminaux gaziers sur la côte est du
canada ces compagnies sont en train
d'explorer maintenant si le nouveau
contexte et nouveaux besoins de
l'allemagne de l'europe change la donne
suffisamment pour aller de l'avant avec
ses projets une visite assombrie par les
critiques de l'ukraine kiev reproche au
canada l'envoi de turbines en allemagne
pour alimenter le gazoduc russe nord
stream 1 ottawa n'aurait pas dû
contourner ses propres sanctions disent
les représentants de la communauté
ukrainienne au canada on demande
d'arrêter tout afin d'isoler
complètement l'un du si sur le plan
économique le choix est justifié mais
tient le premier ministre selon lui il
ne faut pas donner un prétexte au
président russe pour couper davantage
l'alimentation en gaz à l'allemagne nous
n'allons pas le laisser continuer
d'utiliser la politique énergétique
comme arme de guerre on ne doit pas
laisser la russie diviser les alliés dit
le chancelier sortant qui n'a pas manqué
de remercier le canada pour l'envoi des
turbines le canada est déchirée entre sa
solidarité à l'endroit de partenaires
al'approche d'univers difficile où la
facture de gaz sur un salée pour les
ménages allemands le chancelier cherche
un équilibre entre sanction contre la
russie et pression sur le portefeuille
des citoyens la grève à berlin c'est de
perdre finalement l'adhésion de
l'opinion publique s'il n'y a pas des
mesures en place qui permettent de
préserver l'approvisionnement
énergétique de la main justin trudeau
n'a pas de solution immédiate à offrir
pour combler les besoins énergétiques de
l'allemagne le canada veut contribuer à
la transition pour réduire la dépendance
de l'europe envers l'énergie russe mais
l'effort prendra des années ici louis
blouin radio canada ottawa